Our discussion of random
variable so far has involved
nothing but standard probability
calculations.
Other than using the PMF
notation, we have
done nothing new.
It is now time to introduce a
truly new concept that plays a
central role in probability
theory.
This is the concept of the
expected value or expectation
or mean of a random variable.
It is a single number that
provides some kind of summary
of a random variable
by telling us what
it is on the average.
Let us motivate with
an example.
You play a game of chance
over and over, let
us say 1,000 times.
Each time that you play, you win
an amount of money, which
is a random variable, and that
random variable takes the
value 1, with probability 2/10,
the value of 2, with
probability 5/10, the value of
4, with probability 3/10.
You can plot the PMF of
this random variable.
It takes values 1, 2, and 4.
And the associated
probabilities are
2/10, 5/10, and 3/10.
How much do you expect to have
at the end of the day?
Well, if you interpret
probabilities as frequencies,
in a thousand plays, you expect
to have about 200 times
this outcome to occur and this
outcome about 500 times and
this outcome about 300 times.
So your average gain is expected
to be your total
gain, which is 1, 200
times, plus 2, 500
times, plus 4, 300 times.
This is your total gain.
And to get to the average gain,
you divide by 1,000.
And the expression that you get
can also be written in a
simpler form as 1 times
2/10 plus 2 times 5/10
plus 4 times 3/10.
So this is what you expect to
get, on the average, if you
keep playing that game.
What have we done?
We have calculated a certain
quantity which is a sort of
average of the random variable
of interest.
And what we did in this
summation here, we took each
one of the possible values
of the random variable.
Each possible value
corresponds to
one term in the summation.
And what we're adding is the
numerical value of the random
variable times the probability
that this
particular value is obtained.
So when x is equal to 1, we
get 1 here and then the
probability of 1.
When we add the term
corresponding to x equals 2,
we get little x equals to 2 and
next to it the probability
that x is equal to
2, and so on.
So this is what we call the
expected value of the random
variable x.
This is the formula that defines
it, but it's also
important to always keep in
mind the interpretation of
that formula.
The expected value of a random
variable is to be interpreted
as the average that you expect
to see in a large number of
independent repetitions
of the experiment.
One small technical caveat, if
we're dealing with a random
variable that takes values in
a discrete but infinite set,
this sum here is going
to be an infinite sum
or an infinite series.
And there's always a question
whether an infinite series has
a well-defined limit or not.
In order for it to have a
well-defined limit, we will be
making the assumption that this
infinite series is, as
it's called, absolutely
convergent, namely that if we
replace the x's by their
absolute values--
so we're adding positive
numbers,
or nonnegative numbers--
the sum of those numbers
is going to be finite.
So this is a technical condition
that we need in
order to make sure that this
expected value is a
well-defined and finite
quantity.
Let us now calculate the
expected value of a very
simple random variable, the
Bernoulli random variable that
takes the value 1 with
probability p and the value 0
with probability 1 minus p.
The expected value consists
of two terms.
X can take the value 1.
This happens with
probability p.
Or it can take the
value of zero.
This happens with probability
1 minus p.
And therefore, the expected
value is just equal to p.
As a special case, we may
consider the situation where X
is the indicator random variable
of a certain event,
A, so that X is equal to 1 if
and only if event A occurs.
In this case, the probability
that X equals to 1, which is
our parameter p, is the same
as the probability
that event A occurs.
And we have this relation.
And so with this correspondence,
we readily
conclude that the expected value
of an indicator random
variable is equal to the
probability of that event.
Let us move now to the
calculation of the expected
value of a uniform
random variable.
Let us consider, to keep
things simple, a random
variable which is uniform
on the set from 0 to n.
It's uniform, so the probability
of the values that
it can take are all equal
to each other.
It can take one of n plus 1
possible values, and so the
probability of each one of the
values is 1 over n plus 1.
We want to calculate
the expected value
of this random variable.
How do we proceed?
We just recall the definition
of the expectation.
It's a sum where we add over
all of the possible values.
And for each one of the values,
we multiply by its
corresponding probability.
So we obtain a summation
of this form.
We can factor out a factor of
1 over n plus 1, and we're
left with 0 plus 1 plus
all the way up to n.
And perhaps you remember the
formula for us summing those
numbers, and it is n times
n plus 1 over 2.
And after doing the
cancellations, we obtain a
final answer, which
is n over 2.
Incidentally, notice that n over
2 is just the midpoint of
this picture that we have
here in this diagram.
This is always the case.
Whenever we have a PMF which is
symmetric around a certain
point, then the expected
value will be
the center of symmetry.
More general, if you do not have
symmetry, the expected
value turns out to be the center
of gravity of the PMF.
If you think of these bars as
having weight, where the
weight is proportional to their
height, the center of
gravity is the point at which
you should put your finger if
you want to balance that diagram
so that it doesn't
fall in one direction
or the other.
And we now close this segment
by providing one more
interpretation of
expectations.
Suppose that we have a class
consisting of n students and
that the ith student
has a weight which
is some number xi.
We have a probabilistic
experiment where we pick one
of the students at random, and
each student is equally likely
to be picked as any
other student.
And we're interested in the
random variable X, which is
the weight of the student
that was selected.
To keep things simple, we
will assume that the
xi's are all distinct.
And we first find the PMF
of this random variable.
Any particular xi that this
possible is associated to
exactly one student, because
we assumed that
the xi's are distinct.
So this probability would be the
probability or selecting
the ith student, and that
probability is 1 over n.
And now we can proceed and
calculate the expected value
of the random variable X. This
random variable X takes
values, and the values that
it takes are the xi's.
A particular xi would be
associated with a probability
1 over n, and we're adding over
all the i's or over all
of the students.
And so this is the
expected value.
What we have here is just the
average of the weights of the
students in this class.
So the expected value in this
particular experiment can be
interpreted as the true average
over the entire
population of the students.
Of course, here we're
talking about two
different kinds of averages.
In some sense, we're thinking
of expected values as the
average in a large number of
repetitions of experiments.
But here we have another
interpretation as the average
over a particular population.